are the Spice Girls really performing at
the royal wedding how Oprah channeled
Beyonce in a wrinkle in time Plus Kelly
Clarkson makes her voice debut and
Barbra Streisand takes puppy love to the
next level
everybody Denny here we've got a lot of
ground to cover today but first the big
news of the day that Spice Girls reunion
that ladies have been teasing us with
apparently is going down at the Royal
Wedding Scary Spice herself Mel B let
the cat out of the bag today on the real
okay so they invited all the Spice Girls
to the Royal Wedding yes well the Spice
Girls be performing at the reception
[Applause]
so Mel claims the Spice Girls are
bringing girl power to Prince Harry and
Megan Markos wedding in May and while a
rep for the Spice Girls would not
comment on Mel B's interview a source
tells ET there is no plan for them to
perform at the wedding the news comes
after the five ladies gathered for their
first meeting in six years at Jerry's
home earlier this month and how fitting
if they indeed perform since it seems
the Royals are longtime fans of the
Spice Girls check out this little Prince
Harry sandwich between Emma and Victoria
that is Harry's first time meeting the
girls at a concert in South Africa in
1997 now he and his older bro Prince
William were also at the spice world
premiere that same year and now over 20
years later they could spice up his free
wedding amazing I'd like to once again
take this moment to express what a
Beyonce stand I am so in 20 years she
could perform at my wedding that's how
long it'll take me to find love B so you
got time now speaking of Beyonce it
seems that she may have had a bit of
influence when it comes to Oprah's
character in a wrinkle and time et was
at the epic world premiere in Hollywood
last night lady oh and her co-stars
Reese Witherspoon Mindy Kaling and
stormy got all glammed up but there's no
way Oprah could ever top what she wears
in the movie my movie
it's storm Reid's movie you know I get
to play this wonderful character who
helps her along the journey being mrs.
which and seeing my poster going down
sunset I had to stop the car and go whoa
I'm on a bus stop let me tell you
gorgeous know what to say
I'm Beyonce's aunt you want to go home
like every now in the mrs. witch costume
and hair it was actually happy to get it
off at the end of every day it's a whole
lot to put on but when I did the whole
scene out in the middle of the grasses
and the golden grasses I thought I am a
relative of Beyonce moving on to Kelly
Clarkson who may not be a distant
relative of Beyonce but she is equally a
damn delight Kelly made her debut on the
voice last night and I don't think any
coach has had as much
during the Blind Auditions than her
[Music]
[Applause]
how did you start singing like when we
do got that country music Reuben
McIntyre was obsessed with her when I
was
I'll see you Kelly you know she may be
the rookie in the bunch but don't you
love how she just came to win it helps
that she is also our og American Idol
something that's not lost on her she
told us this is a full-circle moment and
there's no bad blood with Idol well
except the fact that they didn't give
her a car I never got my really got a
car but the OGE y'all you didn't get a
car I didn't you know got a car clean
hey he didn't even win playing his mom
his mom got a car a plane I was promised
that Ford whatever it was and I know
what it was but and I needed it my car
look like an accordion I miss you but
you won what did you win I want a career
of working hard for it that you did Kel
and someone who knows a thing or two
about working hard for a very long
career
miss Barbra Streisand and Babs just
revealed something kind of gnarly but
also kind of sweet toupee on how you
look at it apparently she had her dog
cloned twice that's right the 75 year
old revealed a variety that before her
beloved 14-year old dog Samantha died
last year she had the cells taken from
the mouth and stomach so she could be
cloned and that's where Miss violet and
Miss Scarlet come in the dogs arrived at
late last year now we genuinely looked
into this and from what we've learned it
costs about $50,000 to clone one dog so
you do the math but she just had a
Netflix special so she's good for it I
am on the fence on this one but what do
you guys think would you clone your dog
if you could are you cool just hanging
on to the memories
let me know in the comments and you can
catch up on more from Barbara's
interview over at et online.com slash
daily Denny are you guys thank you for
watching I'll see you tomorrow
goodbye